l'irm la plus puissante au monde est en
cours d'installation au cea paris saclay
la pièce maîtresse du dispositif en
aimant supraconducteur de 11,7 et cela
le neurospin va être installée l'aimant
fait 5 m de diamètre et pèse 130 tonnes
la grosse révolution sur cette heymans
et son champ c'est-à-dire en 07 et cela
quand on a lancé le projet léman le en
services de champ le plus intense était
de cette tesla
donc il a d'ailleurs un neurospin il a
été acheté parce que c'était quelques
années après c'est devenu commercial et
ce champ maximum de 11,7 et associé à
une ouverture pour faire parents très
impatient il faut typiquement une
ouverture de 90 cm cette irm permettra
très prochainement la réalisation d'
images inédites de cet organe encore
mystérieux le cerveau le but du projet
mieux connaître son fonctionnement et
surtout ces dysfonctionnements comme la
maladie d'alzheimer ou encore
l'épilepsie
ce qu'on espère c'est pouvoir comprendre
la maladie censé palladienne une région
de cérébral qui s'appelle l'hippocampe
qui est atteinte à un stade très précoce
ce qu'on voudrait c'est pouvoir regarder
ce qui se passe dans cette région pour
pouvoir faire un diagnostic précoce pour
ces patients et aujourd'hui n'a
malheureusement pas de traitement
éventuellement ralentir l'évolution de
la maladie
mais avant que l'irm soit opérationnel
il faudra d'abord effectué de nombreux
tests avec des fruits ou encore des
animaux il devrait être fonctionnel en